[Music]
Uh hi everybody. Uh you probably met me
this morning uh when I greeted you all
to the conference. My name is Lori. I'm
VP of developer relations at Llama
Index. Uh today I'm going to be talking
about Llama Index and what it is uh very
briefly because I've only got 15
minutes. uh and then we're going to talk
about agents and how they are built plus
a very very brief refresher on rag uh
and why it's necessary for agents. Then
we're going to look at some highlevel uh
design patterns that improve the
performance of your agent and we won't
have time to build to dive into how to
build an an agent as well as a multi-
aent system because we've only got 15
minutes so let's go fast. So what is
llama index? We are a bunch of things
start with the most obvious. We are a
framework in Python and Typescript for
uh building generative AI applications.
We are particularly good at building
agents. We also have a service called
llama parse. Llama parse uh will parse
complicated document formats for you. So
PDFs, word, powerpoints, those sorts of
things. These are crucial to uh building
an effective agent uh is being able to
parse your unstructured data in an
effective way. and llama parse will uh
demonstrabably improve the quality of
the agents you build by making the data
easier for an LLM to understand than if
you just try and uh feed these things in
through an open source parser or
something like that. Uh we also have an
enterprise service called llama parse
sorry llama cloud. Uh if what you want
to do is stuff documents into one end
and get a retrieval endpoint out of the
other uh then that is the service for
you. Uh unlike the rest of llama index
it costs money. It is available as a SAS
at cloud.lamindex. llamaindex.ai or you
can get it deployed uh onto your own
private cloud. Uh we also have a website
called Llama Hub uh which is a huge
registry of open- source software uh
that plugs into the framework that
integrates with everything. So if you
need to get your data out of notion or
out of Slack or out of any database in
the world, that is where you find the
adapters. If you want to store your data
in any vector database that exists, the
adapters exist for that. And we also
integrate with every LLM that exists.
So, uh, 400 different models over 80
different LLM providers, uh, including
local ones like Llama 3. Um, oh, and it
also has pre-built agent tools. So, if
you are building an agent, you can just
plug in an existing agent tool without
having to build one yourself. Uh, why
should you use Llama Index? Because we
will help you go faster. That is the
base promise of a framework. Generally,
uh, you have actual business and
technology problems to solve and you
have limited time. A framework is going
to help you uh get past those with uh by
skipping the boiler plate, getting best
practices for free uh and getting to
production faster in general.
Uh what can you build in llama index?
Well, anything obviously, but there's
two things that we are particularly good
at. One is retrieval augmented
generation. Uh and the other one is
agents. Uh both of which you are uh
probably familiar with already from uh
just being at this conference because we
won't shut up about agents at this
conference. Uh it's worth covering why
you would want to build those things
though. Uh so what is an agent? An agent
is uh a dramatically overused term in
the industry. Just about everything is
an agent in 2025. Uh but what I mean
when I say an agent is it is a bit of
semi-autonomous software that can use
tools to achieve a goal without you
having to explicitly specify what steps
it's going to take to achieve that goal.
Uh and the tools can do anything which
is great. they can take retrieve
information or they can take action. Uh
agents are a dramatic departure from
traditional programming. Uh LLMs are
given decision-making power to decide
what tools to use and stuff like that.
That makes them extremely flexible and
powerful. So the time to build an agent
is when that flexibility, that uh
ability to deal with the unexpected or
the unknown uh is going to come in
useful. And when that's really useful is
when you have a a bunch of unstructured
data. Uh LLMs are extremely good at
handling messy inputs and the world is
full of messy inputs. So there's a whole
lot of applications for LLMs. Um in
general, I regard a good agent use case
as any situation where an LLM is
required to turn a large body of text
into a smaller body of text. I think
that is a key principle of agent design
and LLM use in general is that they are
not good at taking a small prompt and
turning it into a big body of text. They
are very good at summarizing stuff down.
So, interpreting a contract, processing
an invoice, uh applying regulations,
summarizing documents, uh a thing where
you need to turn text into less text.
So, a calendar event, a decision or
report, an answer to a question. Those
are good applications for LLMs and good
applications for agents. The most
obvious application of LLM is a chat
interface where you give it questions
and it answers. I encourage you to think
beyond the chatbot. Uh chat bots are a
very 2023 of way way of using an LLM. uh
we believe a much greater addressable
surface is if you integrate them into
existing software. So you use the LLM's
capability to handle messy inputs to
handle unstructured data and turn it
into structured data that it can then
feed make decisions about and feed into
your regular software. That is a really
productive and powerful set of use
cases. Uh and we think it's much bigger
than the market for chat bots. Um,
I've talked a lot about unstructured
data. The reason I talk about it is
because that is where LLMs become really
useful. Um, unless you are building
something extremely generic, uh, you are
not going to be able to get anything
useful out of an LLM by just asking it
questions, you're going to have to give
it contextual data relevant to your
company, to your domain, to whatever
problem set it is that you are working
on. Uh, so you have to feed the LLM your
data. And the problem is that you have
tons of data. And this is the use case
for rag. Uh you take all of your data,
you embed it, which is turning it into
vectors that you can search for in a
vector search. Uh and the you can then
take your query, take your questions
about your data uh and turn embed them
in this into the same vector database
and they will end up mathematically
nearby in vector space to the context
that you fed in that is relevant. So
instead of having to take all of your
data and feed it to the LLM every single
time, which would be tremendously slow
and tremendously expensive, you can just
feed in the most relevant context out of
your data corpus. Uh and uh answer
questions about that. Um this is why rag
will never die. People keep talking
about like larger and larger contexts
and you know more and more powerful
models. Uh it's always going to be
cheaper and faster to send less data
that the LLM has to think about less.
it's always going to be uh you're always
going to get more answers better answers
if the context that you have given your
LLM is uh more specific
uh so agents can use rag as one of their
tools but also uh
um agents so agents need rag uh but rag
also needs agents rag by itself naive
topk rag where you just you know throw
in a query and retrieve the uh retrieve
the most relevant context and feed that
to the LLM that's not going to work very
well for a variety of situations. But
what we've found through lots of
production use cases is that layering an
agent on top of your rag uh will produce
significantly higher quality results. Um
and they're capable of doing things that
rag just can't do. Rag is a simple
question and answer uh robot whereas an
agent can do stuff like introspection
like could this complicated question be
answered more easily if it were a series
of simpler questions. uh do I need to
try extracting that data again because
the data that I got out is nonsense. Did
I just give a sensible answer to your
question or should I try again? That is
something that an agent can do. It can
look at its own responses and improve
itself which rag by itself obviously
doesn't do. Uh so agents improve the
performance of rag both in terms of
speed uh and crucially in accuracy. Um,
in December of last year, Anthropic did
an excellent post about how to build
agents, uh, in which they codified, uh,
some design patterns about how to build
an effective agent that we immediately
recognized, uh, from our own work, uh,
building agents. So, I'm going to go
through them very quickly, and given the
amount of time I have, that's probably
all I'm going to be able to cover. Um,
they are chaining, routing,
parallelization, orchestrator workers,
and evaluator optimizers. Um the first
and most obvious is the chain. Uh you
can use an LLM to do some work and you
pass the output of that to another LLM
and you pass the output of that to
another LLM. Uh it is trivial to build
uh especially in llama index. Uh this is
what uh a chain looks like in lama
index. We use uh an abstraction called
workflows. Uh where you define regular
Python functions that do whatever you
need them to do. uh and you use event
annotations uh to define how you sorry
you use type annotations to define how
events pass from step to step within a
workflow. Uh it is a very simple and
flexible pattern uh that our users like
a lot. Um
so llama index workflows have a built-in
visualizer the output of which you can
see here. Uh this is obviously a chain.
Um
there is much much more to LLM
applications than a chain though despite
uh what the names of some other
frameworks might indicate. Um the next
patternic called out is routing. Uh in
this one you create several LLM based
tools uh to solve a problem uh in
different ways or to solve different
types of problems and you give the LLM
decision-making power to say which of
these tools should I call which of these
different LLM paths should I follow? Uh
again, not that complicated a a concept
and simple to build uh in llama index.
I'm going to uh spare you the code. This
time you can do it using uh branches.
You can just decide that you're going to
split off into your own chain uh and do
a series of uh do another series of work
uh based on the original decision made
by the LLM. Um the next pattern is
parallelization, which is where things
begin to get interesting. Uh anthropic
defines this as running several LLMs in
parallel and then aggregating their
results. Uh and they define
parallelization as having two flavors.
Uh the first is sectioning. Um this is
where you take the same input and you
act on it in completely different ways.
The uh sort of canonical use case of
this is guard rails. So the user has a
query or a piece of input that they want
processed uh and you use one of your
tracks to actually process the data or
to answer the query and you use the
second one of your tracks to query is
this an illegal request? Is this against
my rules? Is this those two qu those two
questions are related but they can be
answered in parallel? And you can use
your guardrails to cut off the answer uh
from your processing if it turns out to
be uh you know illegal or otherwise
undesirable.
Um the other par flavor flavor of
parallelization is voting. This is where
you take exactly the same query and you
give it to uh three different uh three
different tracks. The tracks can be
literally exactly the same LLM because
they are non-deterministic. So it might
not give the same answer every time or
you could give it to multiple different
LLMs which have different capabilities
and different specialties. And then you
take the answers and you allow them and
you see if uh the tracks came to the
same answer. You can take a majority
vote. you can take a unanimous vote. And
what this does is it allows you to uh
limit the amount of uh uh hallucination
that is happening. Uh it's a great way
of reducing hallucination because if you
know three different LLMs come to the
same conclusion, then it's probably not
the LLM just making stuff up because
LLM's hallucinate, but they hallucinate
in different ways. So they seldom
hallucinate to the same answer.
Uh whichever flavor you use, it's
implemented the same way uh using
concurrency. Um we uh llama index
workflows allow you to emit multiple
events simultaneously uh and then
collect those events uh at the other
end. So you can do you can do work
concurrently. Uh
and uh yeah and it I think the
visualization here is particularly
pretty. Um the next pattern is
orchestrator workers. uh you can use an
LLM to look at a complex task like a
multi-part question uh and split it into
several simpler questions and ask each
of those questions in parallel. So this
is how deep research works basically. Uh
it takes a very complicated question. It
says I'm going to I'm going to look at
all of the possible questions that could
come from this deep question. I'm going
to answer them all at the same time and
then I'm going to aggregate all of the
answers that I've got and turn them into
one single coherent answer. This is a
very powerful pattern that is uh doing a
lot of good in the world right now. Uh
this is also implemented using
parallelization. Um and the final
pattern that Anthropic called out is the
evaluator optimizer which is also called
self-reflection. Uh in this pattern you
use the LLM to decide whether or not the
LLM has done a good job. So uh you take
your output, you feed it to an LLM and
you say here was the original question
or here was the original input and the
goal that I had. Have you actually
reached the goal that I had? Uh and if
not, you can get the LLM to generate
feedback and send it back uh to the
original first step and say okay you
almost got the answer but you
hallucinated something or uh you missed
a part of the question or you know
something like that. Um this is again
easy to do in llama index. In workflows,
you just create a loop uh and you can
send yourself back to this step one. Um
and the real power here is obviously
combining all of these patterns. You can
create arbitrarily complex workflows uh
to handle any combination of
circumstances.
Um right near the beginning, uh when I
was defining an agent, I have 60 seconds
left, so I'm just going to go through
the syntax super quick. Uh I said it was
that agents are defined by their ability
to use tools. In llama index, this is
what a tool definition looks like. It is
just a Python function that you have
wrapped uh in a step wrapper. Um,
and the way that you use your tool
function is you just give it to an agent
and the agent will figure out that it is
a tool function and start using it. Uh,
this allows you to create workflows that
are multi-agent systems. I do not have
time to uh explain how multi-agent
systems work for uh this but this is how
you create a multi-agent system in in
llama index. Uh you create uh a function
agent which gets takes a system prompt.
It takes an LLM uh and it takes uh a set
of tools and you can feed uh an array of
agents into a multi- aent system which
then just sort of figures it out by
itself passing control back from one
agent to another. Uh this is technically
one line of code and we're pretty proud
of it. Uh
and that is about it. Um if you want a
full agent workflow and workflows
tutorial, this was the simplest possible
one. The it is available uh at that this
notebook will teach you how to build a
deep research of your own. Uh and with
that, I am pretty much out of time. If I
if you have any questions, I will be
outside in the hallway. Thank you very
much.
[Music]